un casque qui vous parle la société edc
basé à versailles importe en france deux
nouveaux casques connecter depuis
septembre jeux connectés et puis à
partir de ce moment là on peut y mettre
de la musique à vélo se couper du monde
peut s'avérer être dangereux depuis
janvier 2015 la loi interdit de pédaler
avec des écouteurs ou un casque audio
mais il suffit d'un casque de protection
avec enceintes intégrées est la règle
est respectée
les haut parleurs sont intégrés dans le
casque donc ils sont pas sur mes
oreilles ce qui fait que j'entends le
sont de manière très claire j'entends la
musique c'est pas un père ski fis mais
j'entends la musique et j'entends tout
ce qui tourne autour de moi donc
quelqu'un qui m'appelle ray le goût
d'une voiture ou le klaxon je l'entends
tout de suite plus que de la musique le
système bluetooth permet de téléphoner
ou se faire guider par un gps d'autres
modèles à venir proposeront également
une caméra intégrée et s'élargiront à
une pratique plus sportive et aux pistes
de ski et si l'on décide de sortir en
groupe sans téléphone tous les casques
de la même marque entre guillemets
seront compatibles l'un avec l'autre
donc je peux me balader dans les bois ou
en famille en ville dans un rayon de 900
mètres tout en communiquant en full
duplex avec les personnes avec qui je
fais du vélo
donc ça c'est une particularité ces deux
seuls casque sur le marché qui fais à
elle disponible pour l'instant sur des
sites traditionnels de vente en ligne à
partir de 240 euros il pourrait bien se
retrouver au pied des sapins des
cyclistes pour des sorties en famille
mais pas seulement on communique comme
ça dans le bureau